if you want to hang out and talk about
anime theories recommendations and other
fun stuff feel free to join us on
discord and twitch both links are in the
description what is up everybody its
Anna Mak here for anime out Pro and
chapter 103 of the attack on Titan manga
has just become available and even
though I am working on this video pretty
late it's times like this that really
remind me how much I appreciate and love
what I do I get to make our video
reviewing an amazing manga like attack
on Titan and I know that a whole bunch
of you guys are going to take your time
to watch it so thank you so much to all
110,000 of you who subscribed to this
channel it really means so much to me as
always if you enjoyed these reviews be
sure to leave a like to let me know and
if you want to be notified every time I
upload a new review be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification valve so at
the beginning of this chapter we learned
that Falco was saved from the collapsing
building by Reiner who partially
transformed into a Titan in order to
protect him Falco is shocked by what he
sees outside the huge battle going on in
the plaza and he feels utterly betrayed
by Eren whom he knows as mr. krüger
Reiner himself was injured by the
collapsing building and he was knocked
unconscious Falco notices that as a
shifter Reiner should be healing
automatically but this isn't happening
because Reiner has lost his will to live
Reiner knows the horrible things that
he's done to the LD ins on parodies now
the Islanders have come to Marlay for
revenge and he doesn't have the will to
fight he knows that there are good
people on both sides of this battle and
despite being raised to be a warrior he
simply cannot go on like this
now I was one of the people who didn't
want to sympathize with Reiner after
what he did on the island sure he was
following orders but after living with
the Islanders for years he knew they
weren't evil he knew that he was lied to
by the Malayan government he could have
stopped what he was doing at some point
but I have to admit that now after
seeing Reiner in this horrible position
where he knows that no matter what he
does there will be more suffering and
more
tragedy I have to feel for him just a
little bit out in the plaza we see the
jaw tighten beast tighten and peak
scarred Titan battling against the
scouts and they're all being extremely
careful of Levi or as they call him the
Ackerman meanwhile in the showdown
between Aaron's attack Titan and the
warhammer Titan Eren attempts to eat
through the crystal in which Willie's
sister is hiding but he is unable to and
his teeth break Eren mentions that the
crystal is just as hard as Annie's and
this to me confirms that Annie is still
alive if Aaron needs to get through the
crystal to eat the shifter and he cannot
break through it then he couldn't have
eaten annie annie has to be still alive
Aaron tells the Tiber sister that he
still has a trick up his sleeve and he
emerges from the titan body and right
away creates another one this is now the
third time that Aaron has created a
Titan in only a few minutes so we can
definitely say that he has done an
insane amount of training during the
four-year time skin Porco and Peake are
talking about the battle and Porco
believes that they have the upper hand
because they have control of the
battlefield and reinforcements are on
the way and by the way it's crazy how
clearly Peake can communicate in her
Titan form but anyway Peake says that
they have to protect Zeke from the
Ackermann and then classic Zeke fashion
he says as expected of peak that's
exactly right let me know in the
comments if you guys love these peak
memes Zeke then proceeds to use what
looks like some weird fur attack where
he appears to be throwing his fur at the
scouts not sure exactly what this is all
about and then he says something really
interesting
he says Eren Jaeger is not my enemy this
is what we've been talking about for the
past few chapters what is Zeke's real
plan is he actually cooperating with
Aaron just remember that at this point
everyone thinks that Aaron is this
horrible villain just look at how Gabby
considers Aaron to be the worst person
ever and yet at this moment
Zeke still says that Aaron is not his
enemy this to me is more than just some
throwaway sentence and then Zeke says
come out Levi time is running out you
know and at that same moment Levi
appears to be looking at a
pocketwatch then we see a scene where
the Marlon military is gathering at a
port or a harbor and they're getting
ready to send soldiers to a burial as
backup they see what at first looks like
a scared little blonde girl on a fishing
boat and they tell her to get out of
there because it's too dangerous
and that a massive explosion is seen as
the little girl turns out to be Armand
who uses the colossal Titans power to
blow up the entire Marlay and military
Armada before they can reach labarie oh
so much for reinforcements and Arman's
deceptive cross-play strikes again don't
forget that back in the uprising saga
Armand was the one who pretended to be
historia in order to trick the
government when they realize what just
happened mag ass tries to get Gabby and
Falco to get away and meanwhile Porco
loses it and tries to go after Aaron
because he believes that if he can just
take the founding titan then the battle
will be over
even without reinforcements however
Mikasa another Ackerman is there to
protect
Aaron meanwhile the scouts say it's
almost time already and they decide to
take out the machine guns on the cart
Titan by any means necessary
remember how Zeke said to Levi time is
running out you know and then Levi looks
at his pocket watch and now the scouts
say it's almost time and then in the
very next moment Levi strikes the nape
of the Beast Titan and seemingly kills
him the Beast titan falls to the ground
lifeless and the Marlins are shocked
just to make sure that he finishes the
job in the coolest way possible Levi
throws a hand grenade into the cut that
he made on Zeke Snape and Zeke is
seemingly killed and killed bad next the
scouts go after Pete as Sasha Snipes one
of the Gunners on the cart Titan and
soon after the others are Thunder
speared into oblivion by Jeanne the cart
titan collapses its armor destroyed
peaks titan looks to be completely
immobilized and Jean moves in for the
kill but then falco gets in the way and
begs for Jeanne to stop the chapter ends
with the words there's no stopping this
chain of tragedies with an exclamation
mark and a question mark and truly this
is the fundamental question this
chain of tragedies which began way back
during the LDN Empire and which led to
the great titan war and to the attack on
the island and now to the counter
attacked on Marlay continues to claim
innocent lives it doesn't matter who
started it it doesn't matter who is
right because in the end innocent people
continue to suffer on all sides I was
actually born in the former Yugoslavia
right around the outbreak of a major
civil war there back in the 90s and if
you ask the different sides involved
even today they will tell you that the
other guys started it and that it was
the fault of the other side but the fact
is that innocent people suffered on all
sides this is the true nature of war
I've always felt that the Ghibli film
grave of the fireflies was the best
representation of the suffering that
civilians go through in war but attack
on Titan is quickly becoming one of the
best and most complex stories about the
nature of war really an amazing job by
Yama there are two things that I will
say at this point I am afraid that gene
might die in the next chapter the reason
I say this is because I think he will
probably stop himself from attacking
peak in order to spare Falco who is
still just a boy but then Gaby will take
advantage of genes hesitation and use
the gun that she has been carrying
around with her to shoot him I don't
want this to happen but I definitely see
this happening the second thing that I
want to say is that I'm going out on a
limb here and I might look stupid later
but I believe that Zeek is on air inside
and I believe that he is still alive
Levi's attack on the Beast Titan was
planned that is why Zeek said time is
running out just as Levi looks at his
watch and that is why the Scout said
it's almost time right before Levi's
made his move Zeke has been in touch
with Aaron Zeke tried to make sure that
peak and Porco would be sent into the
underground trap
Zeke wanted Reiner to meet with Aaron
Zeke openly says that Aaron is not his
enemy at a time when everyone in Marlay
sees Aaron as literally the devil and I
believe that Zeke made it look like he
was killed by Levi but in reality he
somehow made it out alive and he is on
this
of the scouts this is my prediction and
if I'm wrong I will take the L let me
know if you agree or do you think that
I'm going to look stupid in the next
chapter for saying this also let me know
if you think that a major death is
coming possibly the death of Jean at the
hands of Gabby or do you think that a
major death already happened and Zeke
really is dead if you enjoyed the attack
on titan content on this channel be sure
to leave a like to let me know if you're
new to the channel don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
and we are now posting daily content on
twitter and instagram so be sure to
follow us at anime uproar by the way we
have been trying to showcase some of the
fan art and artwork by members of the
anime opera community so if you're an
artist and you would like to have your
work featured in one of our videos and
on our social media be sure to hit us up
on Twitter and Instagram if it's attack
on Titan fan art then of course we can
feature it in an attack on Titan video
but we also make videos on my hero
academia seven deadly sins Dragon Ball
super and more so by all means feel free
to send that type of artwork as well as
always thank you all so much for
watching it really means so much to me
that people from all over the world
actually stay up and wait for me to
upload these videos thank you all again
and until next time see us bass Cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]